yeah I don't welcome to this video close
game against Prince panic and I'm
actually a rating outside here is it
currently having wrecked my rating so or
waiting on the dogs may be better term
and we have this right we played this
system bishops earphone okay i went with
e 625 last time it was okay there wasn't
anything particularly wrong with it
we're just thinking is there something
else that I could do I don't maybe you
will cancel anyway no so let's get this
wagon check check I don't know can let
be dangerous so black maybe but I know
if anything it can't be much so I think
I'm taking here Bishop g5 I've got f6
well then maybe you can take home now
hmm I cannot cancel let's see five is
attacked but ok let's do this Bishop g5
are also has night B to D 6 b to c 6 the
fact i just develop him
yea the dead space was the most likely
choice at the end I think I should be a
fine here now that's interesting i can
actually try now to unbalance the
position by taking this with the bishop
getting to a random structure where I've
got nights and he's got a bishop no I
know that this is a debatable decision
especially because I'm fine anyway but
ok let's do this to get some sort of
imbalance in this I don't think I'm
risking anything here the dark squares
are not not an issue I believe probably
one of those famous last words the dark
squares are no issue and then like made
on g7 but I really don't think so I have
rookie 89 f 5 what I would like him is
to play an ending against this bishop on
c1 with a night against the bishop the
bishop would be a purely passive piece
defending deform it would be nice I mean
it still why should draw this but it's
something when I can play with some
justification basically forever if six
wants to control f and g five and e5 so
there's no Bishop g5 95 something like
that coming I'm ideas night f5 loopy 8
and then start to trade on the e-file
Oh their connection issue doesn't look
like it i will i understand that he's
trying to find a good setup but it was a
bit long i can just double up only seven
what to do from here move like night
before that's not ultimately do all that
much co-opting form g45 in this position
later it's a bit weird thing son
thinking of Queen at five but I'm bit
unsure what this actually does I mean I
can try and ask him about this do you
want to trade Queens I don't think he
wants to hold it too 333 yeah all maybe
this one huh add stuff to make any
headway in this situation maybe and
maybe 95 and now I will play 94
definitely that looks like i'm trading
this and that i don't mind
three so he wants to try everything and
then draw this hmm maybe the ending
should be a draw okay avoided it so can
we somehow still make something happen
in this position night only six would
probably be better than on c6
yeah stuff to do to do anything now you
have five or sometimes probably is that
soon that's not bad add probably just
equal 96 now can I do some something
with this may be like a b6 now
b6 takes 96 Quincy six takes takes time
learning a draw still a draw from
Queen g3 funny yes yes another thing
doesn't doesn't do much though okay b6
doesn't help really you never take b6 it
doesn't doesn't win okay Jack gets a
perpetual yeah this is the correct
result anyway I'm offered gain drama I
couldn't do much good too much are you
actually wide width of Queen d8 yeah
okay I could have drawn it will anyway
the whole time but you cannot win here
problem I'm not sure maybe around here
it's very little it's very little guy
trying to play with the nike against the
bishop I mean here I mean quite
comfortable shape yeah you can also ask
the computer but it's very difficult to
make something out of it right before
and then then creature here okay yeah
this is a bit that's interesting cannot
move the bishop as him now then never a
possibility sample between these three
hon I played it probably a little bit
too simplistic well this is comfortable
but you're not training ever problem
which is playing on 22 little it's also
thinking here maybe be six but he's got
got this which is also similar oh I'm
getting this back but it doesn't promise
anything yeah probably a draw is the
correct result yes what did I have
something in some genuine leather cuffs
Pietro ok guys thanks for watching